and finally new rule if there's one
thing we've learned from the crisis in
ukraine it's that everyone loves and the
world still needs grown-ass men
thank you
guys
look you can go on about how masculinity
is itself toxic or you can be horny for
vlodimir vladimir zelinski but you can't
do both
if you haven't noticed the internet
these days is filled with posts like
every woman in your life now has at
least a small crush on zelinski and
there's absolutely nothing you can do
about it
if i'm being honest zielinski gives me a
lady boner
badassery is sexy as [ __ ] and i want to
bang zielinski
could it be that as much as women may
want to create the perfect man there's
always going to be a little bit of toxic
mixed in with our masculinity and no
amount of training will turn us into
your favorite twilight character
masculinity is like coffee even when you
decaffeinate it there's still a little
caffeine in there
now there's certainly no denying that
there has been a lot of toxicity
associated with men throughout history
oceans of brutality all of which is
horrible
and some of which is why our species
still exists on earth
there are brave women fighting in
ukraine but the images of people fleeing
all seem to be women and children while
every able-bodied man in ukraine is
sticking around to fight and maybe die
it's not always a great advantage being
a man
and toxic though we may be
we do sometimes come in handy
[Applause]
as much as you may not want to admit it
there's a direct correlation between all
these lady boners for zelinski and the
fact that he's what people used to call
a man's man he can't share right now
he's killing russians
turns out after 200 000 years there's
still a lot of another tribe is coming
to kill us and when that happens you
want a little big dick energy
[Applause]
people magazine's search for sexiest man
of 2022 is already over
last year's winner was cuter but this
guy gets women actually
hot so maybe now would be a good time
for relationship gurus to stop saying
that women just want a man who'll listen
cause zielinski he's not just listening
he's fixing the problem
this is
this is something i've heard for years
that women just want a man who listens
don't try to fix their problems put that
to the test sometime
go over to her house tomorrow and fix
her radiator i bet she loves it
when there's a noise downstairs someone
has to go into the dark and most women
yes still
want a man to do it and if he doesn't or
can't or won't it's not sexy
oh a guy who can't perform i'm melting
no you want the guy who says i don't
need a ride i need ammunition
because i'm john
[Applause]
wick who you also want to [ __ ]
and that's why we owe such a debt of
gratitude to zielinski forget making
america great again he's making america
grind again
i'd say wives are calling out his name
during sex but they aren't because wives
aren't having sex or husbands or singles
researchers have found that americans
across the board are at a 30-year low
for sex
half of americans don't even have it
once a month 44 of adolescent males say
they don't even masturbate males
what are they afraid to touch their own
dicks because a gym sock can't give
consent
since the 1980s american men have
literally been losing their testosterone
with average levels declining by about
one percent per year along with
declining sperm counts
one in four american adults have not had
any sex in the past year and you thought
california was in a drought
[Applause]
the question is why why this sex drought
well i think the answer might be that
men are such [ __ ] now that actual
[ __ ] want nothing to do with them
it's the result of having it drilled
into us in recent years that masculinity
is itself toxic and scary and unevolved
and women don't like it and the ones who
think they do they really don't and if
you think you do you're wrong too what
do you know about you
i think you're probably committing a
microaggression against yourself right
now you owe you an apology
even the act of just asking a girl out
is now seen by many younger people as
overly aggressive there's a feeling that
the attributes traditionally
characteristic of men are inherently
problematic
which sounds a lot like men are born
wrong
type the phrase men are trash into etsy
and you can purchase a slew of swag with
that phrase on it
when the obama administration was trying
to sell obamacare to a skeptical nation
they made an ad featuring someone who
became famous as pajama boy
this is what they put out as an image of
the perfect man
the only thing he loves more than
affordable health insurance is his
therapy cat and emily in paris
that ad might as well say ask your
doctor if chemical castration is right
for you
women have come a long way baby and the
vast majority of that has been long
overdue and very very positive but maybe
in this one way you're a victim of your
own success you can win the battle and
lose the war if you harang men into
becoming less like us and more like you
and end up with someone you have
absolutely no desire to [ __ ]
and that's not good for either of the 71
genders we now have
what we need these days is more sex and
less gender
women aren't attracted to these girly
men they've created the guy you whipped
into total sensitivity isn't sexy to you
anymore there's a special place in a
woman's heart for a man who learns to
suppress his masculinity it's called the
friend zone
[Applause]
and men
this is ultimately on you
she's not holding a gun to your head and
making you a [ __ ] it's always your
choice stop sulking
stop complaining that it's hard to get
laid oh you poor in cells girls don't
want to have sex with you unless you put
in a little effort
so put in a little effort you stupid
lazy [ __ ]
you